[Música]
buenos días y bienvenidos a
desinformando las redes sociales nos
permiten informarnos y movilizarnos
instagram facebook tick tock a través de
estas plataformas los ciudadanos lanzan
alertas pero también habría que
distinguir entre las informaciones
veraces de un lado y las sesgadas o
manipuladas de otro
este año nos reunimos con alumnos de
cuatro liceos franceses en desinformando
respondemos a sus preguntas sobre la
desinformación y les damos consejos para
separar lo verdadero de lo falso
[Música]
y ante una publicación en redes sociales
siempre hay que hacerse preguntas quién
publica esta información
donde ocurren los hechos cuando
cualquier algunos indicios pueden dar
una pista sobre una información falsa
por ejemplo el tono empleado por quienes
suelen difundir informaciones falsas
veamos las siguientes publicaciones
miren con atención
los políticos son pésimos para hacer
montajes se nota que la aguja se dobla
en este vídeo en el que aparece la
vicepresidenta estadounidense llamada
harris la intención es hacer creer que
en realidad ella no se vacunó contra el
cob y 19 que se trató de un montaje todo
está hecho para generar duda veamos en
cámara lenta algunos aseguran que no hay
aguja otros que la aguja parece doblarse
[Música]
segundo indicio la calidad de la imagen
no se ve nada en detalle pero es fácil
conseguir otros vídeos de esa misma
escena busquemos los con la ayuda de
palabras clave vacunación kamala harris
encontramos varios vídeos de medios
estadounidenses que cubrieron el evento
y son de buena calidad
si observamos con atención vemos que la
jeringa si tiene aguja otro indicio está
en los comentarios varios internautas
explican que ese embudo rosado en
plástico retráctil es un mecanismo de
seguridad para prevenir que la enfermera
o el paciente se lastima
haciendo un par de búsquedas más podemos
confirmar que esos embudos si existen
miren también esta captura de pantalla
que circuló en diciembre del 2020 se
supone que pertenece al sitio web del
diario español el mundo muere araceli
primero vacunada en españa'
24 horas después de administrarle la
vacuna
aquí el reflejo correcto es ir a ver el
sitio del mundo pero no encontramos este
artículo normal pues la captura de
pantalla es un montaje fotográfico aquí
tienen el verdadero artículo
araceli de 96 años primera mujer
vacunada contra el cob y de en españa'
ya podíamos intuir que se trataba de una
noticia falsa al comparar la tipografía
pues no es la misma que usa el mundo
esta mujer española no murió 24 horas
después de vacunarse en diciembre del
año pasado de hecho apareció nuevamente
en la prensa española un mes más tarde
cuando recibió la segunda dosis de la
vacuna esté en entonces atentos cuando
reciben capturas de pantalla de
artículos o documentos
intenten siempre buscar el original
[Música]
de expresión de dónde viene el contenido
que veo en redes sociales siempre
debemos preguntarnos quién lo publica y
verificar la información en los motores
de búsqueda aunque eso no siempre es
suficiente veamos este vídeo que circuló
en whatsapp en jordania
nos dicen que esto sucedió en marsella
al sur de francia
en el vídeo unos policías agreden a un
grupo de marroquíes y argelinos pero en
méxico el vídeo también circulaba en
redes con la siguiente leyenda en parís
sacando del metro a punta de toletazos a
todos los que se rehúsan a usar
mascarilla entonces a quién creerle
escuchemos el vídeo de nuevo
[Música]
no lo creo
el audio no es muy bueno pero no hablan
en francés
ahora examinen bien la escena se parece
a una estación de metro en francia y los
uniformes son los que visten los
policías francesas compara para
encontrar el origen de un vídeo el truco
es hacer una captura de pantalla y luego
hacer una búsqueda inversa de imagen
para ello descarguen una aplicación
dedicada a la búsqueda inversa de
imágenes suban la captura de pantalla a
la aplicación y encontrarán todos los
contenidos similares
en sus computadores pueden también usar
un programa gratuito invite descarguen
el vídeo y realiza automáticamente
capturas de pantalla hagan clic en
cualquiera de las miniaturas y
encontrarán todos los sitios donde el
vídeo ha sido publicado en internet
estas dos técnicas permiten deducir que
el vídeo fue publicado por primera vez
en sitios de información rumanos tomen
este artículo y traduzcan intervención
urgente de las fuerzas del orden en
bucarest detuvieron a miembros de las
barras bravas en la estación de metro
nada que ver con hechos ocurridos en
parís o marsella pueden usar estas
mismas técnicas para verificar si una
imagen es auténtica transformen sus
teléfonos en una caja de herramientas
pueden instalar motores de búsqueda
aplicaciones de búsqueda inversa de
imágenes de traducción e incluso de
geolocalización
[Música]
y
la elección presidencial en eeuu se
llevó a cabo tras cuatro años de donald
trump en la casa blanca a él le gustaba
mucho usar el término news para
referirse al tratamiento que la prensa
le daba a una noticia cuando no era de
su agrado pero a la vez él también
difundía informaciones falsas los
periodistas especializados en
verificación del diario 'washington
post' examinaron durante estos cuatro
años las publicaciones del presidente de
trump en su cuenta de twitter sus
discursos y entrevistas al final
encontraron cerca de 30.000 afirmaciones
falsas o engañosas los reclamos sin
fundamento del presidente de donald
trump sobre casos de fraude electoral
llevaron incluso a la invasión del
capitolio por parte de algunos de sus
seguidores
[Aplausos]
y las noticias falsas no se detuvieron
con la elección de joe biden en enero
algunos días después de su investidura
uno de los hijos de donald trump publicó
este vídeo donde vemos a un joe biden un
poco perdido da la sensación de que no
sabe qué hacer
cuál es la idea burlarse de joe biden y
de su edad 78 años y dejarlo como un
hombre débil e incompetente durante la
campaña en efecto donald trump se
refirió varias veces a su adversario
como yo
el extracto de vídeo compartido por
trump juniors es malintencionado en el
sitio youtube de joe biden encontramos
la secuencia original nos damos cuenta
de que el vídeo que circula en internet
fue re dimensionado en el original el
plano es más grande y vemos que yo bailé
en espera a estas dos personas que están
a la derecha para dejar el sitio donde
se encuentra
este ejemplo demuestra que hay que
cuestionarse también sobre las
intenciones de las personas que
comparten contenidos incluso si parece
una broma o una burla porque los
políticos de todas las tendencias pueden
usar noticias falsas para reforzar su
discurso los periodistas deben ser
objetivos el 'washington post' verifica
cada declaración del nuevo presidente
joe biden tal como lo hacía con las de
donald trump
[Música]
como debe ser
una muy buena pregunta detectar una
información falsa puede tomar solo unos
minutos pero a veces la verificación
puede tomar varias horas incluso varios
días además es tal el volumen de
información que nunca podremos verificar
todo lo que sale en redes sociales
afortunadamente hay periodistas que se
dedican a la verificación de hechos
alrededor del mundo ellos forman parte
de una extensa red llamada y fcm
en un año tan solo de la pandemia de
kobe 19 se escribieron 9000 artículos de
verificación por periodistas de 70
países todos somos responsables de lo
que se comparte en redes sociales por
eso hay que tomar el tiempo de verificar
a veces se comparten contenidos sin
verificar los porque coinciden con sus
opiniones o con una causa que defienden
pero eso puede traer problemas veamos
este ejemplo para entenderlo mejor la
defensa de los web ures en china los
webs son una comunidad musulmana
perseguida por el gobierno chino cuyos
miembros suelen ser encarcelados o
internados en los llamados centros de
reeducación lo prueban los testimonios
así como las investigaciones realizadas
por ongs y medios de comunicación muchas
veces los internautas han lanzado
campañas de movilización sobre todo con
el hashtag la vida de los huehues
importan hay varias decenas de
publicaciones que llevan este hashtag en
inglés
y esta foto es utilizada con frecuencia
para denunciar las violencias contra
esta etnia
pero haciendo una búsqueda inverso de
imagen descubrimos que se trata de una
obra de teatro que tuvo lugar en chicago
en el 2004 esta mujer es una actriz y la
imagen no tiene nada que ver con los
huehues cabe preguntarse es
verdaderamente grave lo importante no es
llamar la atención sobre la situación de
los uigures este activista advierte
algunos manipulan con conocimiento de
causa otros comparten contenidos sin
verificar y están difundiendo quizás sin
saberlo una información falsa sean
perspicaces no pierdan credibilidad ni
tampoco les acrediten una causa que les
importa
[Música]
claro que es posible encontrar
informaciones confiables en redes
sociales una imagen de mala calidad
la captura de pantalla de un artículo o
de un documento estos elementos deben
llamar su atención y prender las alarmas
traten de encontrar los originales miren
quién publica la información lean los
comentarios y usen las herramientas de
verificación este programa cuenta con el
apoyo del centro de educación sobre los
medios y la información
muchas gracias a esta división del
ministerio de educación que apoya a los
profesores en la enseñanza de la
detección de las noticias falsas y sobre
todo muchas gracias a los alumnos de
liceo que se interesaron en el trabajo
de verificación de la información y más
ampliamente en la labor de periodista
[Música]